on a normal school day Jalal webe would
be greeting his students instead the
principal of Marianne boys school walks
through empty classrooms and takes stock
of the damage caused by the quake
children can't return until it's deemed
safe but it's not clear how long that
will take
we are afraid of aftershocks that may in
turn lead to more damage in the future I
urge the concerned parties to help us to
continue the educational process here
for the sake of the children the school
and the teachers and the students all
need help
student stuck at home are making the
best of a bad situation Mustafa and
kasim do what studying they can but
mostly they're helping out at their
father's shop
their school is in Rebel controlled
idlib so it's not the first time their
education has been disrupted
we were very scared because of the
earthquake we ran out of a house and we
haven't gone to school since the day it
happened our school was previously
shelled by government forces then the
earthquake caused many cracks in it
it wasn't long ago that their school
looked like this
the building needed extensive renovation
after being hit by a government bomb
the damage of the Quake is yet another
setback to their schooling
the earthquake caused many cracks in the
walls of the school
so we stopped going to school for fear
of after shocks everyone here fears for
our lives and the lives of the students
for now all schools are suspended in
opposition-controlled parts of Syria
students don't know when they'll be back
in the classroom again
some could reopen as early as next week
but others that are badly damaged could
remain closed for a lot longer
Vincent Monahan Al Jazeera